Morning. Hi, everyone. Um, welcome
to our session today.
Uh, we'll be talking about Checkpointless
and elastic training on Amazon
Sage Maker Hyperpod.
I am Airud Visvanathan. I'm a senior
product manager with the Amazon Sage Maker Hyperpod
team. I work primarily
on distributed training at scale
and framework level optimization.
I'm here with uh my colleague,
Arun.
Hi, everyone. My name is Arun Nagarajan.
I'm a principal engineer with the Amazon
Sagemaker AI team.
I provide technical leadership for many
of our products in SageMaker,
including Hyperpot.
Thanks Arun, and we have a special guest. Um,
we also have Antonio from Salesforce.
Hey everyone, I'm Antonio. I'm a
researcher on our Salesforce AI
research team. Um, been using
Hyperpod for almost 2
years, um, and happy to tell you
about some of our experiences and some of the
cool things we've been working on with HyperPod.
Awesome. Thank you.
So let's dive straight in.
So, uh, today, here's the agenda for
our talk.
We'll cover an overview of what
Amazon's SageMaker Hyperpod does.
We'll
set the background on what it takes
to train models at scale, and then
walk through two new features, elastic training
and checkpointless training,
uh, followed by a session from Tony
and close with a few takeaways.
So let's start off with uh what Hyperpod
does.
Amazon Sage Maker Hyperpod
offers you
Essentially,
purpose-built infrastructure for
foundational model training and deployment.
With hyperpod, essentially, we've taken away
all of the heavy lifting associated
with manual cluster
creation and managing your
own uh self-managed environment,
and have sort of built training
and deployment stacks up from the
ground. Essentially
providing you
a, a way to improve your efficiency
of model training,
which in turn reduces the amount of time it
takes for you to train and also lowers
costs.
So the benefits of Hyperpod is that it
offers you an extremely resilient training environment.
The idea is that when you're training on Hyperpod,
you're typically training on multiple
AI accelerators or GPU devices,
and the idea with Hyperpod is that it proactively
screens every. Node or every device
that's part of the training cluster for
health checks
and make sure that the environment is set up correctly
to give you the best training performance.
All of this is done automatically for you
and the environment is managed
by Amazon.
It also offers an extremely scalable environment
for model training where
essentially you can run training workloads
on single spine topology, where
essentially all of these
devices are on the same rack and have the
same physical wiring, so it gives you the best
training throughput and performance.
It supports a variety of
instance types spanning the newest accelerators
for both GPU-based and trainium-based
instances. And essentially Hyperpod
offers this managed service which
is fully observable,
lets you highly customize your environment,
and
has a variety of uh deal armies
that can run on Hyperport as well.
So here's an overview of what Hyperpot
offers. It offers essentially a choice of
both Amazon, EKS or Slum for orchestration.
It's compatible with a variety of frameworks
from PyTorch, Tensorflow,
Nemo, and so on.
And under the hood, it runs
either with the Nvidia
uh Nicol libraries, which is the collective
communication library,
or with the neuron runtime for ranium-based
instances, and it also supports both GPU
and cranium-based accelerators, and
of course you can connect a variety of storage via
your data microcide
for model training.
So, with this background,
let's now transition into the crux of the talk.
So let's step back and think about some of the fundamental
challenges with large scale model
training. I'd like to leave
this up on the screen for a moment, and
the graph here is
data from an organization called
Epoch AI, and they've tracked usage
patterns in terms of cluster sizes used
for model training over the past decade.
We've seen the size of these clusters
grow from 100s of accelerators to 1,000s
to now 100s of thousands of accelerators,
which is nearly a 20 times
increase over the past 10 years. And
so cluster sizes are essentially becoming
larger as
models become more sophisticated.
And the challenge is that as you have
larger clusters,
the likelihood of failure also goes
up. So what we've got
here, and let me walk you through this chart,
is that
every column represents a different
cluster size.
So a cluster with 4 nodes essentially has
32 GPUs, and we go all the
way up to 1000 plus
nodes, which is upwards of 8000
GPUs.
And every row out here
represents the probability
of a node in that cluster failing
during a specific hour.
And so
the way we read this chart is that essentially
as cluster sizes grow larger,
the likelihood of a failure
actually increases, which means that if you're
on a cluster with 1000 nodes
and you have a probability of failure at 0.02%,
that cluster is going to likely
experience a fault every 4
or 5 hours.
So, let's just think about this practically, right, which
means that over the duration of a single day's
worth of training,
this cluster is gonna be experiencing 4 or
5 faults,
each of which can probably take upwards of 1 hour
for recovery operations.
Think about this,
that's essentially 1000
nodes, 8000 GPUs
sitting completely idle during recovery
operations, just waiting for
um recovery and resuming from your checkpoint.
That's essentially a significant
challenge.
So here's what happens when
model training actually kicks off.
So, typically with model training, you have
a sequence of steps where at every
step, there's some amount of data that the model
sees, does a weights
update and then goes on to the next step.
There are periodically model snapshots
or or checkpoints that get saved,
and checkpoints are typically done at
a, you know, a a a cadence or
predefined frequency.
And anytime there's a failure, so in this case
there's a failure that happens after step
number 4,
you need to essentially roll back
to your last safe checkpoint,
redo steps 3 and 4 because they happened
after the last safe checkpoint, and then resume
training. And so during this entire
process of checkpoint-based recovery,
you need to roll back training, redo
a bunch of steps, and then resume training,
which means that you're essentially
paying a cost where a cluster is sitting idle,
and you're redoing work that was already previously
done. So
that's one challenge where as cluster
sizes grow, the probability of failure tends to
increase, and recovery
from failure also starts to become more complex.
Additionally
There are other challenges with clusters
that become larger. So the larger the cluster,
the more likely is this cluster going to be used
by multiple teams within the same organization.
And so you can think of this cluster running
a bunch of fine tuning jobs,
short-lived experiments,
inference workloads,
long-lived pre-training runs, and so on.
And even if you look at
specific inference, you know,
workload patterns,
those are. right, so you have
essentially a peak during the day, and
then a drop off at night,
which means that your cluster utilization
is sort of
going to vary over time, and there are going to be
these pockets of opportunity at night
and during weekends where the cluster is
completely underutilized.
Again, this means millions of dollars
potentially sitting idle,
where other workloads could have opportunistically
used this capacity.
So, with that background, let's talk
about the first feature that we've launched. It's
called elastic training on Amazon Sage
Maker Hyperpod.
So the fundamental challenge that we're solving
with elastic training
is this problem of infrastructure underutilization.
And going back to the previous graph where
we saw,
you know, diurnal cluster utilization patterns.
We
wanted to think about ways to optimize cluster
utilization, and the fundamental
challenge that we have today
is that training workloads are
fixed in the sense that once you kick off a
training job,
you have the same number of nodes and the same number
of accelerators
that participate in this job from start to
finish.
And what this means is that anytime
there are more resources available, these
might be nodes that free up from other jobs
that had finished.
You need to essentially stop this training
job, reconfigure a bunch of hyperparametters,
and then resume training to use
the additional set of resources.
On the flip side, let's say there's a higher
priority uh
workload that's, that needs nodes occupied
by this current training job.
The only way to sort of give back nodes
is to halt this training job completely
and return resources.
So it's this all or nothing choice
that customers face, where you have to
either overprovision the cluster to ensure training
continuity,
or essentially stop the job entirely
to give back resources.
And so this entire overhead of workload
management
can mean customers spend hours sort of observing
resources in their cluster,
manually defining hooks to dynamically scale
up or scale down their training workloads.
So, with elastic scaling on
Amazon Sage Maker Hyperpod,
we've enabled your training workloads to dynamically
scale up and down in response
to available um
available cluster capacity.
And what this means is that
training jobs on Hyperpod can now
automatically scale up when free
resources become available, and scale
back down when those resources are
requested by higher priority workloads.
All of this happens under the hood.
You simply configure your training job,
kick it off,
and then anytime new resources become available,
the job scales up and it scales back
down when those resources get consumed.
In turn, this simplifies your operations
because you no longer need to manually babysit
the cluster,
observe free nodes, and reconfigure
these training parameters manually. This
is taken care of completely under the
hood, and it also
preserves training convergence by ensuring
that the global batch size or the
amount of data that
is seen at every step, remains constant
across the duration of the training job.
With this,
customers can easily get started either
through the Hyperpod recipes, or
you can make custom modifications for
your own scripts to accelerate your training workflow.
So here's what it looks like
um in an animation. So let's say you start off a
job with 4 nodes.
That job now can scale up to 8
nodes because 4 additional nodes
became available.
It's running at 8 nodes, 4 more nodes
become available, so we've gone from 4 to 8
to 12.
At 12 nodes, what happens is there might
be a higher priority workload that needs
a couple of nodes. And so instead of halting
completely, this job is able to scale back
down from 12 nodes to 8 nodes and
continue to run in the cluster.
Once resources open up, it scales back up to 12
nodes and concludes.
What's
notable to observe here is that despite
the number of nodes participating in this workload
fluctuating over time,
the loss function continues to decrease,
which is.
Most important for training continuity.
With that background, let's uh dive under
the hood, and I invite Arun to
walk us through
some of these details in terms of how elastic
training works.
Arun, over to you.
Thanks. Thanks,
Aero Now,
let's dive into the technical architecture
behind elastic training.
We have modified the
Hyperpot training operator to
support elastic training mode.
The operator
works through 4 key features,
and we will talk through them.
The first is the continuous cluster
monitoring.
Where whenever you have new
resources available in your cluster, for
example, you scaled up your cluster
or a currently running training job
completed,
new resources are available,
and this cluster sends a scale-up
notification
for your jobs.
The second is the graceful preemption.
Whenever you have a lower priority
job, currently the only
option for you to give up resources
is to fully terminate the job.
You cannot give partial resources.
Even if the higher priority job did
not need
all of the resources occupied by the
lower priority job,
we simply have to terminate the lower priority
job. With our system,
We are offering an ability so that
you can continue
to run the lower priority job
with reduced resources.
Sure, the lower priority job will
run with
lower throughput,
but your cluster utilization is going
to be high.
This is a game changer
because of two things. One is that
previously
the lower priority job, which would have been
kicked out,
is currently running and making progress.
And the second thing is that your cluster
utilization previously would have been
lower because nobody was going to
use that compute.
Now it's going to be used for
the lower priority job to make progress.
The third part is the automatic training
stack reconfiguration,
and You may know that whenever
you have to scale your training job
from Smaller count
to a larger count or vice versa,
you have to adjust the training parameters
which are critical
to maintaining the training quality and
convergence.
And you typically have to manually
adjust these parameters and restart your job
whenever you change your world size.
Our system offers you
an ability to specify scaling policies.
So that
you can.
You can tell sage maker, here is the
set of parameters
which we need to apply for various
world sizes.
And you don't have to manually be
involved in this process.
The training operator automatically
applies these training parameters
at the right point whenever the scaling activities
happen. And
the 4th 1 is the automated workload
management where
The training operator works
with the hyperpower task governance system
so that your cluster utilization is maintained
high. Your administrator
can continue to set the policies
on limits and quota
on the workloads and teams and
projects involved in your cluster,
and the elastic training still
respects those policies
so that
your cluster utilization can
be maintained high.
The key thing to note here is that
all of this is happening automatically.
Your data scientists
can focus on model building
and not have to worry about infrastructure
stuff. Now,
building on that understanding, let's
walk through
how the system works end
to end during one of these scaling activities.
As we talked about, the system continuously
monitors changes in resources,
including addition or removal of resources.
Once the system observes a
change,
it kicks off a scaling
process. And
this system will send a synchronized
coordination signal to all the training
processes.
Tell that a scaling
event is imminent.
Now the training processes,
they know that
they need to take a checkpoint
so that at a later point in time, you can resume.
The checkpoint typically consists of the
optimizer state and model weights,
and presumably your training code
already has
Code for taking the checkpoints
in the traditional sense.
Now that the operator has
told all the training processes that,
hey, you need to go take a checkpoint,
now the the training operator will
terminate all the training processes.
And restarts them
with a new configuration, that would be
either with more number of training processes
if it's a scale-up event or a lesser number
of training processes if it's a scale down
event. And when these training
processes bootstrap,
they realize that they have been restarted, they
will load the checkpoint,
understand that they need to reconfigure and
redistribute the checkpoint,
and they will continue training.
All of this happens automatically for
you, and it takes
a few seconds for this to complete,
so that your training job can continue
and your GPUs don't have to sit
idle. All
right, now to the fun part. How do you get
started?
We have made this incredibly simple
for you to get started.
If you are using standard architectures
like Lama, Queen, Deep Seek.
You can get started
with zero code change. That's right. There
is no code change needed.
All you have to do is
bring up, bring in your data
and set up the
minimum note count and maximum note count,
and that's it. You can kick off the training
on hyperpod with the
QBCTL command or with the Hyperpod
CLI and you're good to go.
The Hyperpod recipes do
all the heavy lifting needed,
including setting the right parameters to
invoke the Hyperpod training operator
to be running in an elastic mode.
And also
supplying the elastic scaling
policies needed for
various node counts so that
the learning rate and batch size parameters
are optimized for various node counts.
Now, if you, if you
have advanced setup
and you have custom training scripts,
then we have a path for adoption as well. This
is slightly more involved.
Where you have to make some changes to the
job specification.
And you need to supply the elastic
scaling policy where you have to say,
The minimum replicas needed, maximum
replicas needed, and the scaling unit,
which is what we call
the incremental step count.
Then you need to make some changes to
the training script itself.
Where you have to import the
Elastic
event handler from our elastic agent.
And you have to handle the
events sent by our operator. Remember
how we talked about
the operator being responsible for notifying
all the training processes that a scaling
event is imminent, and this is the code
behind that.
You can see that you can,
you can register for those notifications
and you can invoke your
existing checkpoint load and save primitives,
and that's all you need to do.
I want to highlight that even with
the custom adoption path.
The heavy lifting is done
still by the operator
on detecting the resource changes,
notifying all the training processes,
terminating them, and restarting them with a new configuration,
and applying various scaling policies. All
of that is handled for you automatically.
You just need to implement certain hooks
so that the operator and your training code
can work together.
Here's a visualization of the
elastic scaling
job in action. You can see that
we had varied the
world size from 1 to 2 to 8
and uh.
You can see the tokens per second
closely following
the throughput is closely following the
world size available for the training.
You can also observe that
the loss continues to decrease
and the training job was not interrupted
in this process.
To wrap up
Elastic training
Marks a.
Fundamental shift in the way you
think about AI infrastructure.
Long gone are the days where you have
to manually allocate certain
resources for certain jobs
and then you have to play Tetris
to make sure that every job
fits in your system.
We now have a system
where you can configure it
to dynamically adjust
to the cluster
reality,
and we also offer you a mechanism
so that you can continue your training
without sacrificing your training quality
and convergence.
Whether you use the recipes
or you go with the custom path,
the path to adoption is pretty
straightforward.
We encourage you to start with a pilot
project. And see the gains for
yourself. With that, I will
hand it over to Anirud,
who's going to talk about our
next part, which is the checkpointless
training on hyperpod.
Thank you, Arun. All
right, so this is the next shiny feature that
um we have for you today.
Uh checkpointless training on hyperpod
was announced yesterday during Swami's
Keynote. Uh, in this section, we'll
sort of dive deeper into how it works
under the hood.
So, going back to sort of set
the context here, right? The,
the fundamental challenge is that
with large clusters, and
even smaller clusters for that matter,
Checkpoint-based recovery leads to idle
time during training.
So anytime there is a fault,
essentially you need to halt the cluster,
reload your last safe checkpoint, and
then resume training.
But the challenge is that even recovering
from the last safe checkpoint isn't as trivial
as it sounds,
and this is primarily because
with checkpoint-based recovery, there's
a sequence of events where every
event needs to happen first
before the next event can happen. So it's this
cascade of events that are blocking and sequential.
So the idea is that the moment there's a failure,
failure needs to be detected.
Then you need to reinitialize communication
and set up the topology of all of the nodes
that participate in training,
go back, identify your last safe checkpoint,
reload that, reload data loaders,
and a whole sequence of events happen
before you have that first training
step that,
that happens post recovery.
So the challenge essentially here is that
the sequence and the sequence of sets
of steps which are blocking
means the cluster is idle, and with hundreds
of nodes or thousands of nodes, that's
millions of dollars in wasted compute during
recovery operations.
So with checkpointless training,
we've enabled cluster recovery
to drop from hours on self-managed
clusters to under a few minutes on hyperpod.
And in turn, accelerating
recovery times
essentially means that you come to market faster,
because if you're training models over
a long duration.
There can be days often spent in
recovery operations over a
long running training workload,
which now can be done in
basically a few minutes. That's the fundamental
shift in checkpointless training
and what it enables.
The idea with checkpointless training is that once you've
configured and set it up,
failure recovery is fully automated.
And there's no longer sort of any
manual overhead that you need to take care
of when
recovering from training.
The idea is that you are able to maintain
continuous training progress without having
to roll back
to your last safe checkpoint.
In turn, that means essentially no
more lost progress or no more wasted compute
because you essentially pick up from
the current epoch that you are running,
even if in the event of a fault,
without having to roll back a few steps
to the last safe checkpoint.
And so this capability essentially
enables you to scale with ease across
10s to 100s of thousands of accelerators,
and we have pre-created recipes
that you can use for your own training workloads,
as well as offer a suite of components
that you can pick and choose and integrate with your
own custom Pytorch-based scripts.
So, here's an overview of
what checkpoint-based recovery looks
like and versus what checkpointless training
really does.
So, on the left, we have a cluster
which is
showcasing traditional checkpoint-based
recovery, and the one on the right is
essentially checkpointless training.
So we start off where
essentially the cluster might,
you know, experience a fault.
So let's just let this loop in
one sequence. So,
If you look at node 7,
node 7 is going to experience a fault, so
it turns color, and
essentially that's that's a fault that occurs.
With checkpoint-based recovery, you need to
sequentially reinitialize each of those
nodes, which means that it can take
several minutes for that initialization process to happen.
You need to then reload your last
safe checkpoint.
Once that's done, you rehydrate your
data loaders, so
you essentially preprocess all of the data
batches that need to get fed to the model
and then resume training.
This entire sequence of recovery
operations can mean tens of minutes
to potentially an hour
on large clusters versus with checkpointless
training you're able to recover in a couple
of minutes or so.
So here's what performance actually looks
like. The latest
generation of Amazon Nova models were trained
using this capability
on thousands of AI accelerators.
Internally we've tested
with cluster sizes
with upwards of 2000 GPUs,
and traditional recovery, which is checkpoint
based, can be anywhere between 15 to 30 minutes,
but with checkpointless training we're able to recover
in under 2 minutes,
and this is essentially an 80%
improvement in fault recovery capabilities.
We have similar results that hold true even at
smaller cluster sizes. So even with clusters
with 16 GPUs
or 256 GPUs,
we see that traditional recovery might take
about 5 minutes or so,
but with checkpointless training, it's
an order of magnitude faster, and recovery
happens in under a minute.
And what this enables essentially is that
even with clusters, with thousands
of accelerators,
goodput is upwards of 95%. So
you're basically maximizing utilization
of your training infrastructure
with this capability.
So to put this in perspective, right, if
we look at this cluster of
2300 GPUs,
If you have a training run that's spanning
a couple of months,
traditional checkpoint-based recovery overhead
over the duration of that training run
of 2 months can mean multiple
days are spent cumulatively
just in recovery operation.
Whereas with checkpointless training that now drops
to a few minutes,
saving you millions in
essentially uh training costs over
the duration of this training run.
So, with that, with that overview
and uh of performance, I invite
Arun back to walk us through how checkpointless
training works under the hood.
Arun, over to you.
Thanks, Annu. Checkpointless
training is built on 4
key innovations.
That work together to eliminate
bottlenecks in the traditional
distributor training systems.
Let's walk through one by one.
The first one is the optimized
collective communication initialization.
Typically in a distributed system
for training, you have
many processes running across many nodes.
And they need to talk to each other
to exchange data during training.
For example,
in a
distributed data parallel training.
The ranks need to all reduce
the gradients after finishing
the back propagation operation.
However,
before the,
before the ranks can talk to each other, they need
to establish communication with each other,
and typically this is done through a centralized
coordinating system,
which is going to be a bottleneck when we are talking
about the thousands and thousands
of processes
which we demonstrated in our previous slide.
This can add up to minutes
because of this bottleneck in the centralized
initialization system.
With our system, we eliminated this bottleneck
by moving away from the centralized
coordinating
uh system
towards a
towards a peer to peer connection establishment
through hyperpod signals.
This helped us save
minutes and we were able to do this in
seconds.
The second innovation is about
memory mapped data loading.
As you know, the training processes need
access to the data
whenever they need to start training.
However,
the data needs to go through
some sort of pre-processing before the
actual training can begin.
And depending on how complicated your
preprocessing pipeline is.
This
step take up to minutes as well.
You may be wondering what's the big deal about
spending a few minutes before the training start
to finish the pre-processing.
That intuition is right,
however,
When you have failures, you still have to pay
the cost repeatedly. So every time
a failure happens, you need to pay the cost
of
pre-processing your data,
feeding it into
training,
training pipeline.
And during this time, this is a synchronous
operation. All of the compute,
expensive compute is sitting idle.
We solve this by introducing a cache
so that
the preprocessed
data is saved in the cache using
a shared memory and memory mapped
data files
so that when the training processes resume,
they do not have to wait
for reprocessing of the of
the data
which they are, which they are expected to wait
on. In this new world,
they can instantly get started
because. The pre-processed data
is already readily available
for them. The
3rd innovation is the in-process
recovery.
In traditional distributed systems as we
talked about, there are many processes and
Many nodes
Which are collectively running together
and the current failure recovery mechanisms,
what they do is that
you are required to terminate the whole job
and restart it, meaning
all the processes are terminated
and all their state is lost
and the new processes are kicked off
and then they need to
they need to rehydrate their state.
With our system
We are
replacing the failed processes
with hard spare processes.
And we do not touch the healthy
processes. We leave them alone with their
states.
These spare processes join
the training.
And they continue to train
with minimal interruption.
The 4th and most innovative component
is the checkpointless recovery
itself. Traditionally
You will have to take checkpoints. The training
processes need to take checkpoint at certain
intervals.
And when a failure happens,
the processes need to roll back.
Repeat some of the steps and
continue. With
our system building on top of
the In process recovery
What we have
achieved is that the newly joined
training processes
do not need to load from the checkpoint,
but rather
they hydrate their memory
from the other healthy processes
directly using the high-speed network.
This way
The training interruption time
is reduced dramatically,
and that's how we achieve the
sub-minute recoveries that Anil
shared, and also the 95% goodput,
even at the
large scale.
All right, that sounds exciting. So
how do you get started?
Just like the elastic training,
we have made this quite simple for you to get started,
and we have two approaches. First is, of course,
the hyperpowered recipes,
where you can get started if
you're using standard
architectures
by using the recipes, downloading
it, and then using the cubecuttle
command to run it on Hyperpot.
The recipes do the heavy lifting for you,
including setting up the operator to run
in this checkpointless mode,
setting up the
collective communication optimization,
and then the memory memory
map data loader in process recovery,
all of that setup is handled for you
and you can just kick it off.
We think this is the fastest path for adoption
for most teens.
But if you have special requirements
and custom training code,
we have an incremental
adoption path for you.
We have componentized each of these
so that you can incrementally adopt
each component,
observe the benefits, and continue
to Adopt all
of the features together.
The first one is the
Optimized collective communication initialization,
and it's the easiest to adopt.
You just need to set a couple of environment variables
to your training jobs. The first one is instructing
it to not use the centralized
initialization system. The
second one is telling
that it needs to use the hyperpot-based
optimized initialization,
and that's it. You already saved a few
minutes of recovery time every
time a fault happens.
The second one is the memory mapped data loader.
We talked about how we have a cache
where you can store the
pre-processed training data so that during
fault recovery,
you do not need to spend all the time reprocessing
those data.
This one is also pretty easy to adopt.
We have provided a library
with a wrapper, which is quite non-intrusive,
and all you have to do is to point
to a,
a cache location for storing
the memory mapped files.
Moving on to the
in-process recovery and checkpointless recovery
components,
this one
is a little more involved.
You have to do a couple of changes,
including changing the,
the strategy used by your Pytoch
training code
to point to the
Hyperpot specified checkpointless
strategy.
This instructs
The framework to not use the
classic checkpointing, but rather use the restart
list checkpoint that we have implemented.
Secondly,
you do have to wrap your training
loop
with. The hyperpod rapper.
Annotation that we have provided.
Which takes care of the heavy lifting for
health checks
and having the coordination with
the hyperpot by Touch operator.
You can imagine that all the complicated
handshakes which are needed to rehydrate
the state from healthy peers, all of that
is taken care of
for you by these two changes.
I want to conclude by saying that
we took a deep look.
At the existing
framework level limitations that
are present
in the traditional.
Distributor training systems.
And we have eliminated
a lot of bottlenecks from these systems
so that you as our customers
get the most value out of the
compute instances that Hyperpod
offers.
I hope that we have convinced you
to give it a try on all these new features,
and I'm, and I'm excited
what you're going to build with them.
With that,
I am thrilled
to invite Tony,
who's going to talk to us about how
Salesforce is using
Hyperpot.
Tony. Thank
you. Hey
everyone, so I'm Tony,
uh, with Salesforce AI Research,
and we've been hyperpod customers,
uh, for
over 2 years now
and.
I wanted to take a little moment to just
share with you what our use case looks like.
So we have
very heterogeneous workloads, of
course, standard alum training,
but we also have things involving
multimodality, which is a lot of
like speech and image
processing that also happens on the cluster.
We do a lot of fine tuning in RL,
so these are high volume
jobs that are often much shorter than
long running LLM training, um,
and can be kind of bespoke and custom, and
we've got batch inference jobs which,
um,
can run at, uh, varying sizes
or varying time periods.
And checkpointless elastic checkpointless
and elastic training helps us
manage this heterogeny in an
easy way.
So I'm gonna dive a little bit deeper
into what exactly we do
for batch inference.
So I like to use SG Lang. It's
an open serving framework, happens to
be my favorite,
um, and the way we set this up
is we have a job script
which can run on kind of, uh. A
head or a login node style architecture
it's really lightweight. All it does
is load balance to one of your
end worker nodes, and each
worker node is a very simple,
straightforward SGLAN server.
Um, of course all of the workers are
connected by,
um,
disk substrate distributed file system or
S3,
anything of that nature,
uh.
And
I'll explain, I'm gonna dive a little bit
deeper into
one particular
use case within the umbrella of batch inference
because we have several,
um, and I will motivate this
use case as follows,
so.
I want to pause and draw a little bit of contrast
between kind of when we think of AI
or even just learned software
and how that
is a little different than
how we've come to
traditionally consider
human programmed software and one
key contrast is this idea
of nondeterminism.
And you can think about this at each layer
of the stack, so you can think about the app layer
where traditionally
if software was working correctly, it would
give you the same answer every time
and now we have a lot of
AI systems where even in the app layer
there are, you know, key icons
like regenerate and regenerating
responses and trying different prompts and tweaking
is actually a core part of the
application experience.
Even at the algorithmic layer though,
outside of the application you have things
where the neural networks themselves
are sampled in a stochastic
manner and that's actually at the algorithmic
level the entire way that it's supposed to
run again in contrast with
how most applications have been built on
determinis deterministic algorithms
and even going one layer lower into
the stack.
Standard CPUs are highly
deterministic pieces of software, whereas
when you're running on AI
accelerators.
It's actually very it's, it's
in the spec that you can get
nondeterminism when running
uh due to non-commutative properties
of, of the floating point arithmetic on, on,
on these, um, accelerators
and so all of this is to say is that.
There's a very deep way
in which nondeterminism and sarcastic
behavior is embedded in the AI stack,
and
from our perspective at Salesforce we think about
what is the business impact of this because
we have customers
across a variety of industries.
Um, healthcare and financial services
are two industries in particular that are
very much concerned with this concept of
nondeterminism.
Right, so they care a lot about
having deterministic and auditable outputs
and for them
having uh a way
to grapple with this nondeterminism is important
and
they kind of are still figuring out
how to handle this and they're
really.
Trying to navigate this and one thing that
could be of interest to them is
how could you
build AI systems that help bridge
this at kind of various levels
of the stack.
So as I mentioned it was a multi
layer problem that was kind of setting
the broader picture.
Let's now kind of zoom in
and take a look at what actually happens
with an AI model. How does this manifest?
so.
In sampling of a language model,
there's this parameter where
you may have seen, depending on if you've
used things like
an open source or an open uh
open AI API
where there's a temperature flag, and
this temperature flag can be set to
uh various values, zeros,
deterministic in, in theory, um,
again, of course there's there's hardware nondeterminism,
but you can set this higher
and that makes the answers more or less
random.
And so what can happen
is that when you have reasoning models.
And you set too low of a temperature,
the reasoning model will degenerate,
and it will basically produce
completions that are re re
repetitive nonsense.
And
the reasoning models, for
example, many providers no
longer even expose the temperature flag
on those APIs
because they are,
they don't want you to basically run into this edge
case. So they basically set a higher
temperature and you, they don't let you lower it.
Um,
and so you may also recall the
frequency and the
repetition flags, which were
two kind of tools
in the API that helped you.
More easily control this and
kind of mitigate against this
and
as we've seen it doesn't
fully always work so to
motivate why we're studying this problem
you can actually see this screenshot
this is an actual um
this is an actual screenshot from
a
leading
software
agentic coding tool.
You've probably used it if you've written code and
or tested it and as you can see
there is very clearly degenerate repetition.
So while this is infrequent, it does happen in
the wild,
and the main penalties to
address this
fail in all cases or
in all they, they don't succeed in all cases I should say.
And so one work we did that
heavily relied on batch inference on
hyperpod was this LZ
penalty development that we worked
out this year.
So why are we working on a new penalty? As
I mentioned, there's already industry standard
penalties that you can find in standard
inference APIs, the repetition
penalty and the frequency penalty,
but neither of them fully solves the problem.
So what is the repetition penalty? You can think
of it as a binary approach, which
basically says
if the token already appears in the
generation, I'm gonna downsample and make
it less likely for that
token to appear again.
This basically entirely ignores
token frequency. It's a very kind of
crude metric
and so it's also lacking
in memory. It penalizes all tokens
equally regardless of recency, so
it doesn't actually work and experiences up
to 4% to generate repetition rates
for the frequency penalty, which is the other
industry standard,
we can also see that empirically
it doesn't. Fully work
it tries to be more sophisticated than the repetition
penalty by,
uh, actually scaling
the number of
appearances and scaling the penalty based
on this,
but the problem is that it doesn't actually
account or normalize for the length of
the sequence
which can result in a
situation where for very long completions,
which is what you get when you. On
reasoning because the models can basically
think and for thousands
of tokens let's say you get very long sequences
that also the frequency penalty
start to fail catastrophically when
common tokens eventually get banned. So
after basically it's like saying you have a certain number
of commas you're allowed to use in your response
once you exceed that number of commas you
can't use anymore
and what.
Results is the model wants to use a comma but it
can't, so then it makes up another token
in its place, and it starts to
degrade the response until it just
becomes degenerate nonsense.
So I'm gonna tell you about the LZ penalty,
which was, is, is, is you can think of it as a
variant of the two previous penalties, but
it's different on a fundamental level. It's
based on information theoretic principles
that enabled you to more rigorously
address this problem.
So you may have heard of LZ 77,
but I'm certain you've used it because you've
zipped a file on your computer.
So if you've done that,
that's LZ 77. It's a data
compression algorithm that has this property
of being universal, which means it can
basically work for any data type.
Uh, there's a.
Uh, we won't go too much into the details
of it, but essentially what it does is
it lets you look at the historical
parts of the file and then looking
forward to the next chunk of the file, it
allows you to pattern match the next chunk
compared to,
um, let's say a lookup table or a sliding
window of previous chunks, and that pattern
match is what enables the compression.
So as I mentioned, n-gram repetitions,
and it's based on, on pattern matching.
Uh, not just naive frequency
counts.
So how do we actually apply this LZ algorithm
to the language model?
During the sampling of a language model,
it looks like this, where we have a context,
that context gets fed into the language model,
which produces what's called logits.
These logits is what tells the sampler
what probability to assign to every
possible next token.
With the LZ penalty, we in
parallel from the language model
are running the data compression algorithm.
So you can basically think of it as running
GZI or a Vera or something very
similar to GSI right there in parallel with the
language model,
and then we're taking the output of that
data compressor,
and then we're fusing that output with the logits
that come out of the language model,
and then we're using this fused representation
for the sampler,
and what this enables
is that.
The,
the outcomes that the data compression
algorithm
thinks are very repetitive,
become very much uh downweighted
in the
generations from the model.
Uh, because this data compression algorithm is
actually the perfect thing to in some sense, detect
this kind of degeneration and repetition
and redundancy.
So empirically,
uh, we can see here, so the
charts on, on, on the left
are showing average score
across temperatures
and so the temperature again is this parameter
that controls
how random uh the sampler
is. Temperature 0
being the, the value
most there to your left is gonna be greedy
decoding that's perfectly deterministic.
And so as we can swipe or
scan the temperatures we can see
that the LZ penalty there, the NCA
penalty there in red, is consistently within
error bars of the best with no
penalty and the best with the
various two other penalties, frequency
and repetition. Again, those are our baseline penalties.
Um,
And without degrading accuracy, which
is very important, you don't want to degrade your accuracy.
This is, by the way, reasoning model, a
Queen 32 billion parameter reasoning model open
source. Uh,
we can see that the generate repetitions
are uniformly, um, essentially
virtually eliminated with the LSC penalty
uniformly across the board at any temperature.
Below 0.1% empirical uh
discovery of
of any kind of degenerate repetition whereas
all the other penalties
are
maybe generously let's say somewhere between 1
to 4% which
is again pretty infrequent
but it also depends on your perspective because
getting a situation where you actually
do see.
Uh, repetition
is, is, uh, a degenerate repetition is
very bad and so this also again
goes back to
why many of the model APIs
don't actually, don't let you
use reasoning models at temperature zero
to let you kind of
not have to deal with this,
uh, problem of running into these degenerate repetitions.
So here is a little bit more of an in-depth
result. So these heat maps show
every value of the repetition
penalty in terms of its strength.
So again, if you can tune
both the temperature and then you can tune the strength
of the penalty, and the stronger the penalty,
the more it impacts. The
ultimate sampling from the model,
um, that's the very top row
of every heat map is the row
that is the LZ penalty, so that's
kind of like our row, um,
at just the one strength
that you need it you don't
need to tune it
and
again you don't need to tune it because of
the universal property of the
data compression algorithm. It works for any data distribution.
But the other ones you do need to tune and
you can see that
um on the repetition penalty heat maps,
you very often at low temperatures
and occasionally sometimes even at higher temperatures
do run into these
um
kind of catastrophic failures with the generate repetitions.
Bringing things back to inference.
You might be asking, OK, while you're doing all this
extra work with the LSE penalty, how
does it impact your inference performance?
And the answer is that the amount of work you
do with the LSZ penalty compared to the language model
is very small. 1, it paralyzes
very neatly on the GPU,
and 2, as I mentioned, very, very
small. At even a just
a 1.5 billion parameter model,
the throughput slowdown
is less than half a right,
right about 0.5%.
Latency
is, um, nearly
on par, and then as you go up
to. Um, even 32B,
it goes down from 0.5%
to,
uh, 0.03%,
essentially vanishing as the model even
reaches med medium size, the
kind of inference impact of having to do this
extra work for the LC penalty.
So,
one thing that we did was
we were,
you know, this is one line of research we worked on
in parallel with dozens of other
jobs all running on the same hyperpod.
The final set of experiments that we presented,
a subset of them here,
um, you can reference our technical report
for the full set of experiments.
That was validated over about a week with other
jobs scaling up and down.
We went through
over 25 billion tokens and over
a zeta flop of computes.
And
yeah, so
again, being able to run
this and have having
elastic and checkpointless
scaling up and down is
very synergistic with how we wanna scale
up and down our batch inference and all of other job
workloads.
So with that, I'll uh have Anna Rud
come back and wrap us up.
Uh, thanks, Tony.
So, uh, folks, to summarize, we covered
a couple of
key launches, um, in the session.
So with elastic training,
it fundamentally changes the way training
jobs run on Hyperport,
and so we can dynamically scale them up or
down to take advantage of idle capacity
in the cluster.
This ensures training cluster,
training continuity and better cluster
utilization. You can think of elastic
training as sort of playing
Tetris with your cluster capacity,
growing and shrinking jobs as more
capacity becomes available.
And the second key launch is checkpointless
training. This is a paradigm shift in
terms of
training resilience, and instead of going
through a checkpoint-based recovery, which can
take up to 1 hour,
checkpointless training can
Offer you recovery times that are in minutes.
This has good put numbers
upwards of 95% on clusters with
thousands of nodes,
and with that, um, we wrap
up our talk.
Here are some resources,
we're excited to see what you build with
this. We'll be available offstage
for any questions that you might have.
Uh, please do leave feedback on the session
within the app. Thank you so much.